Se suponía que iba a hablar de mi nuevo libro
que se llama "Blink", y que trata sobre opiniones instantáneas y primeras impresiones.
Y que sale en enero, y que espero que todos ustedes compren por triplicado.
Pero estaba pensando sobre esto
y me he dado cuenta que aunque mi nuevo libro me hace feliz,
y creo que haría feliz a mi madre,
no trata realmente sobre la felicidad.
Así que decidí que en cambio hablaría sobre alguien que
creo que ha hecho más por hacer felices a los estadounidenses
que probablemente nadie en los últimos 20 años.
Un hombre que es un gran héroe personal para mí.
Alguien llamado Howard Moskowitz,
quien es famoso por reinventar la salsa de espagueti.
Howard es como de esta altura y es redondo
y tiene sesenta y tantos años y tiene unas gafas enormes
y un pelo gris escaso y tiene una especie de maravillosa exuberancia y vitalidad
y tiene un loro y le encanta la opera
y es un gran aficionado a la historia medieval.
Y de profesión es psicofísico.
Ahora, debería decirles que no tenga ni idea de que es la psicofísica
aunque en algún momento de mi vida salí dos años con una chica que
estaba obteniendo un doctorado en psicofísica.
Lo cual debería decirles algo sobre aquella relación. (Risas)
Hasta donde sé, la psicofísica trata sobre medir cosas.
Y Howard tiene un gran interés en medir cosas.
Y se graduó con su doctorado de Harvard
y puso una pequeña consultora en White Plains, Nueva York.
Y uno de sus primeros clientes fue -- esto fue hace muchos años atrás, a principio de los 70 --
uno de sus primeros clientes fue Pepsi.
Y de Pepsi fueron a ver a Howard y le dijeron:
"Sabes, hay una cosa nueva llamada aspartamo,
y nos gustaría hacer Pepsi Diet.
Nos gustaría saber cuanto aspartamo deberíamos poner en
cada lata de Pepsi Diet, para tener la bebida perfecta." ¿Bien?
Esto suena como una pregunta increíblemente sencilla de responder,
y eso fue lo que Howard pensó. Porque Pepsi le dijo,
"Mira, estamos trabajando con una franja de entre el 8 y el 12 por ciento.
Cualquier cosa por debajo del 8 por ciento de dulzura no es suficientemente dulce,
cualquier cosa por encima del 12 por ciento es demasiado dulce.
Queremos saber, ¿cuál es el punto exacto de dulzura entre 8 y 12?"
Ahora, si les doy este problema a resolver, todos ustedes dirían que es muy fácil.
Lo que hacemos es que hacemos una gran muestra experimental de Pepsi
para cada grado de dulzura -- 8 por ciento, 8,1, 8,2, 8,3,
así hasta 12 -- y lo probamos con miles de personas
y trazamos los resultados en una curva
y tomamos la concentración más popular. ¿Correcto? Realmente simple.
Howard hace el experimento, y obtiene los datos y los traza en una curva
y de pronto se da cuenta que no es una bonita curva de campana.
De hecho, los datos no tienen sentido.
Es un desastre. Está todo enredado.
Ahora bien, la mayoría de la gente en este negocio, en el mundo de las pruebas de alimentos y demás,
no se preocupan cuando los datos resultan enredados.
Piensan, bien, sabes qué, entender lo que la gente piensa sobre los refrescos de cola no es tan simple.
Sabes, a lo mejor cometimos algún error durante el proceso.
Sabes qué, mejor hagamos una suposición,
y simplemente apuntan y se van por el 10 por ciento, justo en el medio.
Howard no es tan fácil de convencer.
Howard es un hombre con un nivel particular de principios intelectuales.
Y esto no era suficientemente bueno para él
así que esta pregunta lo torturó durante años.
Y le daba vueltas y decía, ¿qué estaba mal?
¿Por qué no tiene sentido este experimento con Pepsi Diet?
Y un día, estaba sentado en una cafetería en White Plains
tratando de sacar alguna idea para un trabajo para Nescafe.
Y de repente, como un rayo, la respuesta vino a él.
Y esta era que cuando analizaron los datos de Pepsi Diet
estaban haciendo la pregunta equivocada.
Estaban buscando la Pepsi perfecta
y deberían haber estado buscando las Pepsis perfectas. Confíen en mí.
Esto fue una revelación formidable.
Esto fue uno de los más brillantes descubrimientos en toda la ciencia de los alimentos.
Y Howard en seguida se fue de gira
e iba a conferencias alrededor del país
y se ponía de pie y decía:
"Han estado buscando la Pepsi perfecta. Están equivocados.
Deberían haber estado buscando las Pepsis perfectas."
Y la gente lo miraba con incomprensión y decían:
"¿De qué estás hablando? Esto es una locura."
Y decían, tu sabes: "¡Fuera de aquí! ¡Siguiente!"
Intentaba conseguir proyectos y nadie lo contrataba -- pero estaba obsesionado
y hablaba sobre ello, y hablaba y hablaba.
A Howard le encanta la expresión judía
"para un gusano en un rábano, el mundo es un rábano."
Éste era su rábano. (Risas) ¡Estaba obsesionado con esto!
Y finalmente, tuvo un avance. Fueron a verlo de Pepinillos Vlasic
y dijeron, "Señor Moskowitz -- Doctor Moskowitz --
queremos hacer el pepinillo perfecto." Y él dijo:
"No existe el pepinillo perfecto, sólo existen los pepinillos perfectos."
Y fue a verlos de nuevo y les dijo: "No sólo necesitan mejorar el pepinillo normal,
necesitan crear uno picante."
Y de ahí fue de donde obtuvimos los pepinillos picantes.
Entonces la siguiente persona vino a verle, y fue Sopas Campbell's.
Y esto fue aun más importante. De hecho,
Sopas Campbell's es donde Howard forjó su reputación.
Campbell's producía Prego, y Prego, a principios de los 80s, perdía mercado frente a Ragú,
que era la salsa de espagueti dominante en los 70s y en los 80s.
Ahora, en la industria, no sé si esto les interesa
o cuanto tiempo tengo para profundizar en esto.
Pero técnicamente hablando -- esto es un tema aparte --
Prego es mejor salsa de tomate que Ragú.
La calidad del tomate es mucho mejor, la mezcla de especias es muy superior,
se adhiere a la pasta de una manera más satisfactoria. De hecho,
ya en los 70s llevaban a cabo la famosa prueba del plato hondo entre Ragú y Prego.
Tenían un plato de espagueti y la vertían encima, ¿de acuerdo?
Y la Ragú se iba toda al fondo, y la Prego se mantenía encima.
Esto se denomina "adherencia."
Y, de todas modos, a pesar del hecho de que eran superiores en adherencia
y de la calidad de su pasta de tomate, Prego estaba en problemas.
Así que fueron a ver a Howard, y le dijeron, arréglanos.
Y Howard miró en su linea de productos, y dijo:
"Lo que tienen es una sociedad de tomate muertos".
Así que dijo: "Esto es lo que quiero hacer".
Y se metió en la cocina de sopas de Campbell's,
y elaboró 45 variedades de salsa de espagueti. Y las varió
de todas las formas imaginables en las que puedes variar la salsa de tomate.
Por dulzura, por nivel de ajo, por acidez, por lo agrio, por "tomatosidad",
por los sólidos visibles -- mi término favorito en el negocio de la salsa de espagueti. (Risas)
De cualquier forma imaginable en la que puedas variar la salsa de espagueti, él la varió.
Y cogió la colección entera de 45 salsas de espagueti, y se fue de gira.
Fue a Nueva York, fue a Chicago, fue a Jacksonville,
fue a Los Ángeles. Y trajo gente por montones. A grandes salones.
Y los sentó durante dos horas y les dio,
durante el transcurso de esas dos horas, diez boles.
Diez pequeños boles de pasta, con una salsa de espagueti diferente en cada uno.
Y después de que comían cada bol tenían que puntuarlo, de 0 a 100,
por cuán buena creían que era la salsa de espagueti.
Y al final de ese proceso, después de hacerlo durante meses y meses,
tenía una montaña de datos acerca de
cómo el pueblo norteamericano se sentía respecto a la salsa de espagueti.
Y entonces analizó los datos.
Entonces, ¿buscó la variedad más popular de salsa de espagueti? ¡No!
Howard no cree que exista tal cosa.
En cambio, miró los datos y dijo
"Veamos si podemos agrupar estos diferentes datos en conjuntos.
Veamos si confluyen alrededor de ciertas ideas.
Y si te sientas, y analizas todos estos datos sobre la salsa de espagueti
te das cuenta que efectivamente todos los norteamericanos pertenecen a uno de tres grupos.
Hay gente a la que le gusta su salsa de espagueti normal,
hay gente que a la que le gusta su salsa de espagueti picante
y hay gente a la que le gusta con trocitos extra.
Y de esos 3 hechos, el tercero fue el más significativo.
Porque en aquel tiempo, a principios de los 80s,
si ibas a un supermercado
no encontrabas salsa de espagueti con trocitos extra.
Y en Prego miraron a Howard, y le dijeron,
"¿Nos está diciendo que uno de cada tres norteamericanos se mueren por la salsa de espagueti con trocitos extra
y que todavía no hay nadie atendiendo sus necesidades?" Y él dijo ¡Sí! (Risas)
Y entonces Prego volvió sobre sus pasos
y reformuló completamente la salsa de espagueti
y sacaron una línea con trocitos extra que inmediata y completamente
se apoderó del negocio de la salsa de espagueti en este país.
Y durante los siguientes 10 años, hicieron 600 millones de dólares
con su línea de salsas con trocitos extra.
Y todos en la industria vieron lo que Howard había hecho y dijeron:
"¡Oh, dios mío! ¡Hemos estado haciendo todo mal!"
Y así es como empezaron a aparecer siete clases diferentes de vinagre
y 14 clases diferentes de mostaza y 71 clases diferentes de aceite de oliva,
y al final incluso Ragú contrató a Howard
y Howard hizo para Ragú exactamente lo mismo que había hecho para Prego.
Y hoy en día si vas a un supermercado, uno realmente bueno,
y miras cuantas Ragús hay,
¿Saben cuántas hay? ¡36!
En seis variedades: Queso, Light, Robusto,
Rico y Abundante, Viejo Mundo Tradicional, De jardín con trocitos extra. (Risas)
Esto es lo que Howard logró. Esto es el regalo de Howard a los estadounidenses.
Y bien, ¿por qué es esto importante?
Es, de hecho, tremendamente importante. Les explicaré por qué.
Lo que Howard hizo es cambiar fundamentalmente la manera en que la industria de los alimentos piensa
acerca de cómo hacerles felices.
La primera suposición de la industria de los alimentos solía ser
que la forma de averiguar lo que la gente quiere comer --
lo que haría feliz a la gente -- es preguntarles a ellos.
Y durante años y años y años y años, Ragú y Prego tuvieron
grupos focales donde sentaban a toda la gente y les decían:
"¿Qué quieren en la salsa de espagueti? Dígannos que quieren en la salsa de espagueti."
Y durante todos esos años -- 20, 30 años --
a lo largo de todas aquellas sesiones de grupo,
nadie nunca dijo que querían con trocitos extra.
Incluso cuando al menos un tercio de ellos, en el fondo de sus corazones, en realidad sí los querían.
(Risas)
¡La gente no sabe lo que quiere! ¿No es cierto?
Como Howard adora decir: "La mente no sabe lo que la lengua quiere".
¡Es un misterio!
Y un paso críticamente importante para entender nuestros propios deseos
y gustos es darnos cuenta que no siempre podemos explicar que es lo que en el fondo queremos.
Si les hubiera preguntado a todos ustedes, por ejemplo en esta sala, qué es lo que quieren en un café,
¿saben que habrían dicho? Todos y cada uno de ustedes habrían dicho "Quiero un tostado oscuro, rico y generoso."
Es lo que la gente siempre dice cuando se les pregunta qué es lo que quieren en un café.
¿Qué te gusta? ¡Tostado oscuro, rico y generoso!
¿A qué porcentaje de ustedes verdaderamente les gusta un tostado oscuro, rico y generoso?
Según Howard, a entre el 25 y el 27 por ciento de ustedes.
A la mayoría de ustedes les gusta el café poco cargado y con mucha leche.
Pero nunca jamás se lo dirán a alguien que les pregunte qué es lo que quieren,
que "Quiero un café poco cargado y con mucha leche." (Risas)
Así que esto es lo primero que Howard hizo.
Lo segundo que Howard hizo es que nos hizo darnos cuenta --
este es otro punto muy crítico --
nos hizo darnos cuenta de la importancia de lo que a él le gusta llamar segmentación horizontal.
¿Por qué es esto crítico? Es crítico porque
esta es la forma en que la industria de los alimentos pensaba antes de Howard. ¿Bien?
¿Con qué estaban obsesionados a principios de los 80? Estaban obsesionados con la mostaza.
En particular, estaban obsesionados con la historia de Grey Poupon. ¿De acuerdo?
Solía haber dos mostazas. French's y Gulden's.
¿Qué eran? Mostaza amarilla. ¿Qué hay en la mostaza amarilla?
Semillas de mostaza amarillas, cúrcuma, y páprika. Eso era la mostaza.
Grey Poupon se presentó con una Dijon. ¿De acuerdo?
Una semilla de mostaza café mucho más volátil, un poco de vino blanco, un toque de nariz,
aromas mucho más delicados. ¿Y que hicieron?
Lo pusieron en un frasquito de vidrio con una maravillosa etiqueta esmaltada
para hacerlo parecer hecho en Francia, aún cuando se hace en Oxnard, California.
Y en vez de cobrar un dólar con 50 por una botella de 225 gramos,
como French's y Gulden's hacían, decidieron cobrar cuatro dólares.
Y tenían aquellos anuncios, ¿no? Con el tipo en el Rolls Royce
comiendo la Grey Poupon, el otro Rolls Royce se para al lado
y le dice, ¿tienes un poco de Grey Poupon?
Y el caso es que después de que hicieron eso ¡Grey Poupon despegó!
¡Se hizo con el negocio de la mostaza!
Y para todo el mundo la conclusión de esto fue
que la manera de conseguir hacer feliz a la gente
es darles algo que sea más caro, algo a lo que aspirar. ¿No?
Es que le den la espalda a lo que piensan que les gusta ahora
y que apunten a algo superior en la jerarquía de las mostazas.
¡Una mostaza mejor! ¡Una mostaza más cara!
Una mostaza de mayor sofisticación, cultura y significado.
Y Howard vio aquello y dijo: ¡Esto está mal!
La mostaza no existe en una jerarquía.
La mostaza existe, al igual que la salsa de tomate, en un plano horizontal.
No hay mostaza buena ni mostaza mala.
No hay mostaza perfecta ni mostaza imperfecta.
Sólo hay distintas clases de mostazas que se ajustan a diferentes clases de personas.
Él básicamente democratizó la manera en que pensamos sobre el gusto.
Y, nuevamente, por eso debemos estar enormemente agradecidos con Howard Moskowitz.
Lo tercero que Howard hizo y quizás lo más importante
es que Howard se enfrentó al concepto del plato platónico. (Risas)
¿Qué quiero decir con esto?
Durante muchísimo tiempo en la industria de los alimentos
existía la sensación de que había una manera, una manera perfecta, de preparar un plato.
Vas a Chez Panisse, te dan el sashimi de cola roja
con semillas de calabaza tostadas en una reducción de algo de algo.
No te dan cinco opciones para la reducción, ¿verdad?
No te dicen: ¿quieres la reducción con trozos extra grandes, o quieres la... ¡No!
Sólo te dan la reducción. ¿Por qué? Porque el chef de Chez Panisse
tiene una noción platónica acerca del sashimi de cola roja.
Así es como debería ser.
Y ella lo sirve de esa forma una vez y otra vez
y si no estás de acuerdo con ella, ella te dirá,
"¿Sabes qué? ¡Estás equivocado! Así es como mejor debiera ser en este restaurante".
Y la misma idea también impulsó a la industria de los alimentos.
Tenían una idea, una noción platónica, de lo que era la salsa de tomate.
¿Y de dónde venía eso? Venía de Italia.
¿La salsa de tomate italiana cómo es? Está triturada, es poco espesa.
La cultura de la salsa de tomate era poco espesa.
Cuando hablábamos de salsa de tomate auténtica en los 70s
hablábamos de la salsa de tomate italiana. Hablábamos de las primeras ragús.
Que no tenían sólidos visibles, ¿cierto?
Que eran poco espesas y que, si ponías un poco encima
se colaba hasta el fondo de la pasta.
Eso es lo que era. ¿Y por qué estábamos aferrados a eso?
Porque, A, pensábamos que lo que haría a la gente feliz
era ofrecerles la salsa de tomate culturalmente más auténtica
y, B, pensábamos que si les dábamos la salsa de tomate culturalmente auténtica
la recibirían con los brazos abiertos.
Y esto complacería al número máximo de personas.
Y la razón por la que pensábamos esto, en otras palabras,
la gente en el mundo de la cocina estaba buscando los principios universales de la cocina.
Estaban buscando una sola forma de tratarnos a todos nosotros.
Y hay una buena razón para que ellos se obsesionasen con los principios universales,
porque toda la ciencia, a lo largo del siglo 19 y gran parte del 20,
estaba obsesionada con principios universales.
Psicólogos, investigadores médicos y economistas estaban todos interesados en descubrir
las reglas que gobiernan la manera en que todos nosotros nos comportamos.
Pero eso cambió, ¿verdad?
¿Cuál ha sido la gran revolución en la ciencia de los últimos 10, 15 años?
Ha sido la transformación desde la búsqueda de principios universales a la comprensión de la variabilidad.
Ahora en la ciencia médica, no queremos saber necesariamente cómo
funciona el cáncer, queremos saber cómo tu cáncer es diferente de mi cáncer.
Cómo mi cáncer es diferente de tu cáncer, perdón.
La genética ha abierto la puerta al estudio de la variabilidad humana.
Lo que Howard Moskowitz estaba haciendo era decir que esta misma revolución
necesitaba darse en el mundo de la salsa de tomate.
Y por ello, le debemos estar agradecidos a Howard.
Les daré un último ejemplo de variabilidad y este es -- oh, lo siento.
Howard no sólo creía eso, sino que fue un paso más allá,
que consistió en decir que cuando perseguimos principios universales en la comida
no sólo estamos cometiendo un error, sino que nos estamos ocasionando un enorme perjuicio a nosotros mismos.
Y el ejemplo que él usó fue el café.
Y el café es algo con lo que él trabajó mucho, con Nescafe.
Si les pidiera a todos ustedes que probaran y trajeran una marca de café,
una preparación o tipo de café que les hiciera a todos felices,
y entonces les pidiera que valoraran ese café
la puntuación media en esta sala para el café sería alrededor de 60 en una escala de 0 a 100.
Y, si por el contrario, me permitieran dividirlos en grupos de café,
tal vez tres o cuatro grupos de café,
y pudiera preparar café sólo para cada uno de esos grupos individuales
sus puntuaciones irían de 60 a 75 o 78.
La diferencia entre el café de 60 y el café de 78
es la diferencia entre el café que tomas a regañadientes
y el café que te hace extremadamente feliz.
Esa es la última, y creo que la más bella, lección de Howard Moskowitz.
Que aceptando la diversidad de los seres humanos
encontraremos un camino más certero a la verdadera felicidad.
Gracias.